servus skills und herz bekommt zu einem
neuen video leute kennt ihr diesen
moment wenn ihr morgens aufsteht in den
spiegel schaut euch denkt dass es heute
gar nicht mehr so scheiße aus leute es
gibt einen youtuber den ich sehr geehrte
schauer aus amerika ist er vielleicht
kein paar von euch den und der hat so
eine sache die entmachtung zwar
reagierte da auch seltsame instrument
kommentare und ich habe gedacht warum
mache ich das nicht auch mal rund leute
ob welche person würde man gehen auf
welchen instagram account wenn man in
deutschland selbst am instrument
kommentare finden will
hatte karl ritscher natürlich und wir
leute werden heute mal analysieren
welche menschen auf diesem instrument
dokumentieren was diese schreiben und es
wird auf jeden fall gestörte kommentare
seit heute fangen habe mit diesem bild
die leute ganz normale pose würde ich
sagen so stehe ich auch meistens auf
meinen zu bebildern da was sofort
auffällt ist dass der fokus bei diesem
bild ganz klar auf dem linken ellenbogen
liegt jetzt hier wirklich sehr guten
szene gesetzt hat ja auch leute ich muss
ich wirklich waren dieses video wird
extrem ihr könnt euch bestimmt denken
dass er sehr extremer leute kommentieren
es ist wirklich so wenn ihr noch nicht
ganz bereit seid dass sich damit
wohlfühlt dann schon das nächste video
an ich habe es gesagt habe ich gewarnt
werden unter diesem bild kommentiert zum
beispiel der account titten arsch bilder
bei mir gibt's alles umsonst was gibt's
umsonst chicken nuggets auf dem account
noch keine beiträge fahren leute und die
bio hauptmann der stadt wie auch
vollkommen um
ich würde nicht von deinen arsch und
titelbilder umsonst schatzes verfolgt
das auf eine schicke ein geiles schwanz
bild notgeil und daher diese risiken so
schlimm wird's heute das ist wirklich
eine ganz dunkle ecke des internets sie
kommentiert zum beispiel luisa s
kleine rote kommentiert 340 im audi s6
herz imogen wenn wir wie count
draufgehen
ohne witz ich hoffe dass meine oma
niemals dieses video sieht bin käuflich
angebote pdm freue mich auf ein
wiedersehen wir haben es noch nie
gesehen aber das okay block b oder das
macht nichts
wo ist der sinn dabei leute warum
schreibt man in seine bei und dass man
parking käuflich ist wenn ich jetzt
schreibe ok drei euro 30 watt was kurze
plugin einschicken lang ist aber eher 20
chicken nuggets acht euro ok acht euro
würde ich das so schreiben hey ich würde
gerne für acht euro kaufen kein problem
natürlich will ich allerdings schreiben
hai dann kurz warten und dann schreiben
ich würde gerne kaufen würde es nicht
gehen weil ich natürlich schon in
irgendein problem in der luft dann
übrigens wenn ihr noch ein instrument
sucht wo niemand nicht in leder leggins
post sondern zum beispiel kuchen ab lag
dann könnt ihr auch instrumente zweite
folgen dann wie ein nächster stelle
dieses bild hier wo katja wie wir alle
erkennen gerade versucht die selbst eine
backpfeife zugeben und unter diesem bild
haben wir neben gefühlt einer milliarde
splish splash images noch eine person
die kommentiert ich muss der name is
trouble zensieren hat gerade jemand
ständer
ich liebe berlin liebe freut mich dass
du auch durchaus für gemüse offen bis
und auch auf seine ernährung achtet aber
was hat das mit dem bild zu tun
wirklich das kommt jetzt privat deswegen
kann ich auf den namen zeigen heute 666
card von 666 kommentiert ablecken lecker
wisst ihr leute bei normalen menschen
gibt peter zwischen okay was ich denke
was du mein dümmste teil meines hirns
denkt der primitivste teil meines hirns
und das was ich sagen oder schreiben
die meisten entscheiden dann fehlt dann
wenn sie auf der straße irgendwie netten
jungen mann nette frau sehen gehen die
meisten menschen nicht hin und machen
sex jetzt sondern halten sich an der
stelle eben zurück das hat schon mal
hier bei dieser person nicht
funktioniert und ihre gedanken waren
ablecken lecker perfekt dann leute mache
weiter auf unserer reise wir haben
dieses bild hier
ich glaube dass die person auf der
rechten kakás letztes orio aufgegessen
hatten wir gerade hat er bei dem versuch
sehen sich dieses oder zurückzuholen
fonds entsprechend untergeschoben wird
danach welche gleich richtig geile
kommentare ich glaube ich musste ihn
aber wieder zensiert geht uns auf den
account leute ich kenne euch das scheint
mir das ist als das klingt so diesem
vater der sein eigenes kind lebt aber in
dieser situation haben wie ein ich habe
nachgeschaut iranischen geschäftsmann
ist eine ein mann könnte mein eigener
vater sein weiter her und er kommentiert
bei katja very good bye dir etwas andere
richtung live welche mittel bewunderte
missgeburt was dachten sich darin
verkorksten eltern leibliche mittel
bewunderte missgeburt verstehe ich jetzt
nicht ganz was er damit sagen will
na ja und dann haben wir noch den
zehnjährigen der kommentiert meine augen
haben kriegt alles klar soweit okay
leute ich muss eine sache weichen als
ich mir dieses video überlegt haben als
ich mir gedanken gemacht habe habe ich
mir nicht gesagt dass es so ehren
loswerden würde wirklich das ist einfach
ehren los auch wenn man einfach nur
sobald und irgendwie sowas nicht damit
beschäftigen ich glaube man lustig
machen muss trotzdem diese kommentare
lesen und irgendwie eklig da rein
versetzen und nein ich lasse mich jetzt
erstmal drei schon mal ein buch schon
weine aus china investiert und so weiter
und bis zum nächsten mal